-I'm so happy to see you all.
Thank you so much
for coming back to the show.
And I'm so happy to see you.
-Yeah, finally.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers ]
-Last time -- Last time you were
on the show, you were sick.
-I was.
-Yeah.
And I'm so happy to see
you're not sick anymore.
And I filled in.
I filled in for you.
I was in the band for
three minutes, four minutes.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers ]
-You looked very good
with a blonde wig, though.
-Thank you very much.
Did you bring that blonde wig,
or did we find one?
-No, no, now it's my turn.
Please, Jimmy.
[ Laughter ]
-No, no, no.
It's you.
But here's me performing
with Maneskin
last time they were on the show.
-Nice.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I'm a bit jealous.
-Sorry, darling.
You really can't see
the difference.
-You can't tell the difference
at all, yeah, yeah.
How did you rate --
did you see the performance?
-Yeah, I saw it.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
Let's just leave it at that.
-I don't know.
You were hot, though.
You were hot.
-I was hot.
-I was a bit jealous.
-You know what made me laugh?
This is how much
your band loves you.
They brought around
a cardboard cutout of you
because you were sick.
No, for real.
And we were posing
with pictures with you.
You were here when you didn't
even know you were here.
-I look excited, though.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It was an honor to play
with you guys
and to try
to step in your shoes.
I tried.
I couldn't even hold a candle.
I can't hold a candle to you.
Come on, you guys rock.
Congratulations on getting
nominated for a Grammy
for Best New Artist!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yes!
-Yes!
-Maneskin, Best New Artist,
now Grammy-nominated!
-Ah, yes.
-Forever.
Forever you can say that.
-Yeah.
-Where were you
when you heard the news?
Did you freak out?
Were you excited?
-Yeah, no.
We were in L.A.
We were writing
the album, actually.
-Yeah.
-And -- No, we were touring.
-I don't know.
-I don't remember.
It was early --
-Who -- Who heard it first?
-I was, 'cause I'm, like,
the early bird of the band.
[ Laughter ]
And it streamed in the morning,
so I was the only one, like,
really awake
in front of the television.
They were all waking up
and getting dressed and stuff.
And when they said our name,
I started screaming.
And we were actually
shooting a video for this
because we wanted, like,
to share the reaction,
but we couldn't because it was
too vulgar, too aggressive.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, I heard him, like,
started banging on my door.
Ooh.
And I was like, "Okay.
What's wrong?
What have I done?
I'm [bleep]."
-They all thought --
They all thought
we didn't get the nom.
-I thought just you wanted
to kill me or something.
I was like,
"What did I do wrong?"
-You thought he wanted
to kill you?
-I was like, "Aah!",
locking the door.
-You're locking the door,
like, "Stop, stop!"
You were just so excited,
just yelling out curse words
and screaming?
-Exactly.
-Yeah, that's fantastic.
Well, congratulations.
This is a big deal.
[ Cheers and applause ]
No matter what happens,
you're always Grammy-nominated.
That's it.
No matter what happens.
Also, another cool thing,
if you can get cooler
than getting nominated
for a Grammy,
but Mick Jagger chose you
to open for the Rolling Stones
in Las Vegas.
[ Cheers and applause ]
He chose you.
He's like, "I want this band.
I want this band."
What was it like when you get
that call from Mick Jagger?
You're like --
-"Whatever."
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, yeah.
-"Maybe we can't do it."
-Just another day.
-Just another day
in the music business.
-Where was it?
Was it a stadium?
-It was in Vegas, yeah.
Yeah, it was like our biggest --
like, our first stadium,
so it was crazy.
And, also, it was iconic
'cause we got the chance
to talk to him,
and he was, like, so nice
and knew a lot
of our music and stuff.
And then, we met Keith Richards,
and he was like,
"I don't know
who the [bleep] you are,
but they told me you're good,
so..."
We were like, "Okay."
-"But you play real instruments,
so keep going."
-"You play real instruments."
-And then he vanished.
-And then he -- that's what
Keith Richards does.
He says nice and iconic things,
then he vanishes.
I want to talk about
the new album, "Rush."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Congratulations.
It's out.
Can you explain
the cover of the album?
-[ Laughs ]
-Well...
-Sure.
-It's behind the meaning.
-Yeah.
That's half of the meaning.
-The meaning is behind.
-We cannot show you that.
[ Laughter ]
-You can imagine it, though.
-But there's a girl
jumping over you guys.
-Yeah.
-And what I like is the
expression on your faces.
Can we just zoom in just to --
[ Laughter ]
Everyone's got
a different expression.
-Yeah.
Yeah.
-Is that kind of expressing
what you guys
are going through right now?
-Exactly.
-Kind of.
-More or less.
-Good guess.
-Yeah, it was like, we tried to
represent the whole year
we've been through
and all of the different moods
we had and how each one coped,
like, with the stress
and everything, also.
And it's represented, like,
as something cool
'cause she's jumping
and we can see under her skirt.
[ Cheers ]
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-But also as something that
could fall over you, you know?
So it's like this double thing.
-Yeah.
I mean, it feels like
you've been around.
But it's all new.
I mean, you're new artists
and all.
But every time you perform,
you crush, I will say.
I'm a fan.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Every time I've seen you.
And it's nerve-wracking.
I go, "Oh.
Are they gonna do it again?"
And you do it again.
And I love
that you keep doing it.
So, congratulations to you.
You're doing something tonight.
What are you
playing tonight for us?
-Once again, "Beggin'" --
No.
[ Laughter ]
I'm joking.
-"Gossip"!
-We're playing "Gossip" with --
-Finally.
-With Tom Morello.
-With a special guest.
With Tom Morello.
-The legend.
-Come on.
[ Cheers and applause ]
How does it go?
Do you get excited when you get
to play with Tom Morello when --
You know,
I have a photo here of --
You guys started
busking in Rome.
That's how you got your start.
This is you guys --
[ Cheers ]
What was a --
What is a big day for you guys
at busking, moneywise?
-A good day meant like...
-50?
-...between 20 and 50 euros.
But the most important thing
was going back home with zero
[bleep] offs from
the pedestrians.
-Oh, 'cause people
would scream that at you.
-Which happened rarely,
honestly.
-Yeah, that was very hard
not to get insulted.
-Usually you would get insulted
by at least one or two people
per day?
-Even more, even more.
-At least.
-At least?
And what would you --
Would you play covers
or just originals?
-Mostly covers.
We had, like, two originals.
-Also, yeah,
and some were our songs.
-Two originals.
-And would the cops just
break you up and go,
"Get out of there"?
-Very often. We would be like,
"Oh, my God, I'm sorry.
We didn't know that,"
and then like wait five minutes
hidden and then --
-Do it again.
-We were like, "Oh, my God.
We didn't know that."
-That's what's it's --
it's called, drive, everybody.
That's what it's called.
You've got it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm so happy you're here.
Thank you so much.
You look great in person.
I'm so happy to see you guys.
Maneskin, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Their new album, "Rush,"
is available now!
Number one, by the way,
in over 20 countries.
Congrats on that, too.
They're performing with
Tom Morello when we come back!
Stick around!